[Music]  kendall Jenner really wants you to know  she is not pregnant I try and keep  things as private as I can but when it  comes to a point and it's not a big deal  the 22 year old flaunted her taut tummy  in this sexy new year snap with another  smoldering supermodel Bella Hadid the  caption new year same us the AB bearing  pic came at just after Kendall responded  to pregnancy rumors that popped up after  she posted this shot she replied to MTV  Australia's speculation about the  picture ever so elegantly with I just  like bagels okay I confused you with  Kendall cuz Kendall's pregnant and I  know that for a fact that one Kendall  previously shut down pregnancy rumors  with her sister Kourtney Kardashian on  The Ellen DeGeneres Show back in October  as of now they are the only two  kardashian-jenner sisters and not  expecting new additions in the new year